been a tough weekend for many parts of
Florida and the southeast of the US with
hurricane Irma and I am NOT a
meteorologist this is not the Weather
Channel and there's plenty of coverage
of the impact of that particular
hurricane but I want to keep building on
our sort of conversation and
understanding about the connection
between climate change and individual
weather events and like I told you last
week whenever there's a hurricane the
anti-science crowd says it's not time to
talk about climate change that's
politicizing a natural disaster my view
is any opportunity to talk about climate
change is a good one and there is a
relationship between extreme weather
events and their frequency and severity
and climate change but it's a complex
relationship again I told you this last
week generally speaking when you have a
warmer ocean that serves is more fuel
for storms to build rather than
dissipate there's a very important
number that tells us so much more about
how and why climate change connects to
more and more severe hurricanes and it's
called the clausius-clapeyron equation I
have no idea if I'm pronouncing that
correctly but that's roughly what it is
some people call it the clausius
clapeyron relation and it's a physical
law and it predates the modern
politicization of climate change by
several centuries in fact and quite
simply what that relation states is that
every time air temperature goes up by
one degree Celsius that air can
effectively hold seven percent more
water well you might be saying great we
don't have to worry we use fahrenheit in
the US so the impact won't really be as
bad of course that that would be moronic
and the significance with hurricanes and
extreme weather is pretty direct here's
a quote from Gabriel vecchia's a
professor of geosciences at Princeton
University he said a warmer ocean makes
a warmer atmosphere a warmer atmosphere
can hold more so all other things equal
the same storm in a warmer planet would
give you more rainfall now this is not
literally true right that the saying the
atmosphere
can hold 7% more water it's more
accurate to say there's more energy in
the weather cycle so it can move more
water it's it's sort of a shorthand
right the the atmosphere can hold 7%
more water and of course climate change
encompasses a lot more than just water
we've talked about pollution we've
talked about the oceans ability to carry
life as a result of acidification of
oceans it's a long list but as far as
weather is concerned this summer's
hurricane season has been particularly
warm in the region of the Atlantic where
hurricanes forms sea surface
temperatures have been anywhere from
half a degree to a degree Celsius above
average the higher temperatures mean
that hurricanes will store more water
which they will eventually dump when
they make landfall which means bigger
storm surges and more flooding but let's
talk a little bit about the math because
very often the devil is in the details
the most important thing I can tell you
about this equation is that for every
degree of temperature increase you add
7% to the holding capacity of the
atmosphere not 7 units this means that
it is an exponential increase it's sort
of like compound interest if you put a
hundred bucks in an account earning 5%
interest that first year you earn five
dollars but next year you earn 5% of the
hundred and five dollars that you now
have meaning in year two you're adding
five dollars and 25 cents
same thing with the air temperature
meaning that one degree increase adds 7%
the second degree increase adds another
7% which is a growing amount of water
that can be conceivably held add that to
the fact that damage caused by rainfall
or flooding is also exponential right
with snow you can think about it two
inches of snow doesn't really cause much
more chaos than an inch of snow 1/3 inch
of snow it starts to get a little dicey
the third inch of snow causes a lot more
chaos than the second inch and so on
until eventually you've got enough snow
that power lines become down etc same
thing with rainfall and that's why all
of this Pat the financial damage grows
exponentially it's all exponential
equations and that's
what a lot of people don't get when they
say well we've had a little more
rainfall in the last few years or a
couple more hurricanes or whatever there
are still plenty of people in that anti
science community who just think this is
no big deal yeah and one thing that
they'll point to is that there hadn't
been a major hurricane to hit the US
since 2005 I think I didn't think 12
years and now that kind of puts aside
you know that we had some pretty
significant storms including Hurricane
Gustav superstorm Stamey's sandy aside
from that though it could just be luck
you know yeah well of yours it's not a
long time yeah and also the world's a
pretty big place it's not just the
United States that were talking about
just because they're not forming here
and maybe the jet stream is bringing it
to a different direction we could be due
for more it's unconscionable to
basically write off all of the concerns
in that way it truly is and we're gonna
continue talking about it and I think
there's no better opportunity than when
we're having these huge hurricanes to
actually talk about the broader issues
that we're facing the video you just
finished watching was made possible by
you through the membership program you
can sign up for membership at david
pakman.com slash membership we are
viewer supported independent media you
can use the coupon code
I voted 17 for a 40% discount off of
your membership